The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, guys.
Let's get started.
So today, we're going
to talk about Tor.
And we actually have
one of the authors
of the paper you guys read
for today, Nick Mathewson.
He's also one of the
main developers of Tor.
He's going to tell
you more about it.
NICK MATHEWSON: Thank you.
So at this point,
I could start out
by saying, please
put your hands up
if you didn't read the paper,
but that wouldn't work.
Because it's embarrassing
not to have read a paper
you're supposed to have read.
So instead, what I will ask
is, think of your birthday.
Think of the date of your birth.
If the last digit of the
date of your birth is odd,
or you didn't read the paper,
please raise your hand.
OK, that's not far from half.
So I'm guessing most
people read the paper.
Means of communicating that
preserve our privacy enable
us to communicate more
honestly to gather better
information about the
world when we are less
disinhibited from speaking
because of possibly justified
possibly unjustified social
and other consequences.
So this brings us to
Tor, which is a anonymity
network that I've been working
on for the last 10 years
with some friends and
colleagues and so on.
[INAUDIBLE] there's a set of
volunteer operating servers,
about 6,000 of them.
At first, it was
just friends of ours
that Roger Dingledine
and I knew from MIT.
After that, we built
up more publicity.
More people started
running servers.
Now it's run by nonprofits,
private individuals,
some university teams, possibly
some of you here today,
and no doubt some
very sketchy people.
We've got about 6,000 nodes.
We're serving on the order
of hundreds of thousands
to millions of users
depending on how you count.
It's kind of hard to count,
because they're anonymous.
So you have to use statistical
techniques to estimate.
And we're doing on
the order of terabytes
per second worth of traffic.
Lots of people need anonymity
for their regular work.
Not everyone who
needs anonymity,
though, thinks of
it as anonymity.
Some people say, I
don't need anonymity.
I'm perfectly fine
identifying myself.
But there's broad
perceptions that the privacy
is necessary or useful.
And when regular citizens
use anonymity stuff,
they tend to be doing it
because they want privacy
in search results, privacy in
doing research on the internet.
They want to be able to
engage in local politics
while not offending local
politicians, and so on.
Researchers frequently
use anonymizing tools
to avoid gathering biased data,
biased by geolocation based
services that might
be serving them
in particular different
versions of things.
Companies use
anonymity technologies
for protection of
sensitive data.
For instance, if I can
track all of the movements
of the legal team for some
major internet company,
I can probably, just by tracking
when they're visiting their web
server from different
places around the world,
or where they're visiting
the company [INAUDIBLE]
different places
around the world,
learn a lot about which teams
are collaborating with which.
And this is
information companies
would like to keep private.
Companies use also the anonymity
technology for doing research.
So a major router
manufacturer for a while--
I don't know if this
is still the case--
would regularly serve different
versions of its product sheets
to IP addresses associated
with its competitors
in order to make reverse
engineering trickier.
And they found this out by
using our software and said,
hey, wait a minute, we got
a different product sheet
when we came in from Tor
than we did coming directly.
And it's also kind of
normal for some companies
to serve other companies
versions of their websites
to emphasize the employment
opportunity sections.
Regular law enforcement needs
anonymity technologies as well
to avoid tipping off people
during investigations.
You do not want the
local police station
to appear in the web logs of
somebody you're investigating.
And regular folks
need it, as I said,
for avoiding harassment
because of online activities,
to research stuff that
might be embarrassing.
If you live in a country with
uncertain health care laws,
you might want to avoid
creating too much public record
of what diseases you think
you might have and so on,
or what dangerous
hobbies you might have.
And also lots of criminal or bad
folks use anonymity technology.
It's not their only option.
But if you are willing to
purchase time on a bot net,
you can buy some
pretty good privacy
that is not available
to people who
think that bot nets are amoral.
And Tor, and anonymity
stuff in general,
are not the only multi-use
technology out there.
Let's see, the average age
of a graduate is about 20.
So around when you were
born-- have you talked
about crypto wars at all?
PROFESSOR: No.
NICK MATHEWSON: No.
During the 1990s, it was sort
of an up-in-the-air question
in the United States about
to what extent civilian use
of non-backdoor cryptography
should be legal,
and to what extent it
should be exported.
That kind of came
down pretty decisively
on the side of cryptography
should be legal and exportable
during the '90s and early 2000s.
And although there's some debate
about anonymity technology,
it's more or less
the same debate.
And I think it's going to end
in more or less the same way.
So here's an outline of my talk.
I'm going to give you that
little introduction I gave you,
talk a little bit about
what we mean by anonymity
in a technical sense, talk a
little about our motivations
for getting into it.
Then I'm going to kind
of walk you through step
by step how you start
with the idea of,
we ought to have some
anonymity, and how
do you wind up with the
design of Tor from that point.
And I'll mention
some branching off
points where you might
wind up with other designs.
I'll pause to answer some
of the cool questions
that everyone has sent in
for their class assignment.
I'll talk a little bit about
how node discovery works,
which is an important topic.
And then I'll sort
of by show of hands
pick which of these
advanced topics to cover.
I guess we're calling them
advanced because they're later
in the lecture.
And I can't read them all,
but they're all really cool.
I'll mention some
related systems
whose designs you
ought to check out
if this is a topic that
interests you and you'd like
to know more about it.
I'll talk about future work
that we want to have done at Tor
and I hope that we'll
have time to do some day.
And if there's time for
questions, then I'll take them.
And I've got nowhere I need
to be for the next hour or so.
So I and my colleague David over
there-- can you wave your hand,
David-- will be hanging
around somewhere and talking
to anyone who wants to talk.
So right, anonymity--
what do we mean
when we talk about anonymity?
There are lots of
informal notions
that get used in informal
discussions, in online, and so
on.
Some people use
anonymous to mean,
I didn't write my name on it.
Some people use
anonymous to mean, well,
no one can actually
prove it's me
even if you suspect strongly.
What we mean is a number
of notions expressed
in terms of the
ability of an observer
or attacker on a network to
link participants to actions.
These notions come out
of a terminology paper
by [INAUDIBLE] that
you find a link
to on freehaven.net/anonbib/,
the anonymity bibliography that
I help maintain.
It should list most of the
good papers in the field.
We need to bring it
up to date to 2014,
but it's pretty useful.
So when I say anonymity,
generally what I mean
is Alice is doing some activity.
She's-- what should
Alice be doing?
Alice is buying new socks.
And there's some attacker here.
Let's call her Eve for now.
Eve can tell that Alice
is doing something.
Preventing that is not
what we mean by anonymity.
That's called unobservability.
Eve can tell possibly that
someone is buying socks.
Again, that's not what
we mean by anonymity.
But what we hope is that
Eve cannot tell that Alice
in particular is buying socks.
And we mean that both
on a categorical level--
Eve should not be
able to conclude
through rigorous mathematical
proof, this is Alice,
she's buying socks--
but also, Eve should not
be able to conclude
probabilistically it's likelier
that Alice is buying socks than
some randomly selected person.
And also, we would
like Eve not to be
able to conclude after
observing many Alice activities,
Alice sometimes buys
socks, even if I
don't know some particular
activity of Alice's is
a socks purchase.
There are other ideas
that are related.
One is on unlinkability.
Unlinkability is it's like a
long-term profile of Alice.
So for instance,
Alice has been posting
as-- I'm never good at
picking names for my example.
Alice has been posting as Bob
and writing a political blog
that would disrupt
her career, that
would offend her
department head and disrupt
her career as a computer
security [INAUDIBLE].
So she's been writing as Bob.
Unlinkability is Eve's
inability to link Alice
to a particular profile.
Final notion--
unobservability, some systems
try to make it impossible to
even tell that Alice is online,
that Alice is connecting to
anybody at all, that Alice
is doing any active.
These are rather hard to build.
I'll talk a little bit
more about to what extent
that they are useful later.
Something that is
useful in that area
is you might want to
conceal that Alice
is using an anonymity
system, but not
that she is on the internet.
That's more achievable
than concealing the fact
that Alice is on the
internet entirely.
So why did I start working
on this in the first place?
Well, partially because
of the engineer's itch.
It's a cool problem.
It's an interesting problem.
Nobody else was
actually working on it.
And my friend Roger
got a contract
to finish up a stalled
research project
before the grant expired.
And he did it well enough that
I said, hey, I'll join up.
And [INAUDIBLE].
I'll join in.
After a while, we
formed a nonprofit
and released everything
as open source.
So that's part of it.
But for deeper
motivations, I think
humanity has got a lot
of problems that can only
be solved through better
and more dedicated
communication, freer expression,
and more freedom of thought.
And I don't know how to
solve these problems.
All I think I can do
is try to make sure
that what I see as
inhibiting discussion,
thought, speech,
becomes harder to do.
So that's [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
STUDENT: So I know there are
many good reasons to use Tor.
Please don't see
this as criticism.
I'm just curious,
what is your opinion
as far as criminal activity?
NICK MATHEWSON: What is my
opinion on criminal activity?
Some laws are good.
Some laws are bad.
My lawyers would tell me
never to advise anyone
to break the law.
My goal was not to enable
criminal activity against most
of the laws I agree with.
In places where criticising
the government is illegal,
then I'm in favor of criminal
activity of that kind.
So in that case, I
suppose I was supporting
that kind of criminal activity.
My stance on whether it's
a problem that an anonymity
network gets used
for criminal activity
in general, to the extent
that there are good laws,
I would prefer that
people not break them.
I would, however, think that any
computer security system that
does not get used by criminals
is probably a very bad computer
security system if
the criminals are
making any kind of good
decision making policy.
I think that if we go
around banning security
that works for criminals, we
wind up with insecure systems.
So that's more or less
where I stand on it.
I'm not really the
philosopher of it, though.
I'm more of the programmer.
So I'm going to be giving
really trite answers
to philosophical
and legal questions.
Also, I'm not a lawyer and
cannot offer legal advice.
Do not take anything
I say as legal advice.
That said, [INAUDIBLE], a lot
of these research problems
that I'm going to
be talking about
weren't even close
to being solved.
So whey do we start anyway
instead of going straight
into research?
One of the reasons, we
thought that a lot of them
wouldn't get solved unless
there was a test bed to work on.
And that's kind
of been borne out.
Because Tor has kind of become
the research platform of choice
for lots of work on low
latency anonymity systems.
And it's helped the
field a lot in that way.
But also, 10 years on, a
lot of the big problems
still aren't solved.
So if we had waited 10 years
for everything to get fixed,
we would have been
waiting in vain.
So why do it then?
Partially because we thought
that having a system out there
would improve long-term
outcomes for the world.
That is, it's really easy
to argue that something that
doesn't exist should be banned.
Arguments against civilian
use of cryptography
were much easier to
make in public in 1990
than they are today.
Because there was
almost no civilian
use of strong cryptography then.
And you could argue that if
anything stronger than DES
is legal, then
civilization will collapse.
Criminals will never be
caught, and organized crime
will take over everything.
But you couldn't
really argue that that
was the inevitable consequence
of cryptography in 2000.
Because cryptography had
already been out there,
and it turned out
not to end the world.
Further, it was harder to argue
for a cryptography ban in 2000
because there was a large
constituency in favor
of the use of cryptography.
That is, if someone
in 1985 says,
let's ban strong
cryptography, well, banks
are using strong cryptography.
So they'll ask for an exemption.
But other than
that, there weren't
a lot of users of
strong cryptography
in the civilian space.
But if someone in
2000 said, let's
ban strong
cryptography, that would
be every internet company.
Everyone running an HTTPS page
would start waving their hands
and shouting about it.
And nowadays, strong
cryptography bans
are probably unfeasible,
although people
keep bringing back the idea.
And again, I'm not
the philosopher
or political scientist
of the movement.
So some folks ask me,
what's your threat model?
It's good to be thinking
in terms of threat models.
Unfortunately, our threat
model is kind of weird.
We started not with an
adversary requirement.
But we started with a
usability requirement.
The usability requirement
we gave ourselves to begin
is, this has to be
useful for web browsing.
This has to be useful for
interactive protocols.
And it actually
needs to see use.
Subject to that, we want
to maximize security.
So our threat model has
lots of weird corners
in it if you actually
write it out as,
what can an attacker do, under
what circumstances, and how?
And that's because we've
set ourselves the goal of,
it has to work for the web.
And I'll return to that
in a minute or two.
But let's sort of
talk about now how
we can use forward anonymity,
how we build forward anonymity.
So here's Alice.
She wants to buy socks.
So OK, let's say that
Alice runs a computer.
Let's call it R for relay.
And this computer relays
her traffic to-- I
want to say socks.com,
but I'm afraid that'll
turn out to be something
horrible, so zappos.com.
Yeah, they sell socks, too.
All right, so Alice wants to
buy some socks from zappos.com.
And she's going through a relay.
Well, I said Alice runs a relay.
Any eavesdropper who's
looking at this will say,
that's Alice's computer.
It's probably Alice.
All right, so let's have
somebody else run a relay
and have lots of other
users all visit it.
I'll call them A2
and A3, because there
aren't enough standard
cryptography person names-- buy
books, tweet cat pictures.
This is like 80% of what people
do on the internet, right?
So now we have three people all
going into this relay, three
streams exiting.
Someone who's watching the
relay can't easily correlate--
should not be, we hope, but
we return to that later--
that this Alice is buying
socks, this Alice, buying books,
this Alice is tweeting cat pix.
Well, except if they're watching
this side of the connections,
they can see Alice
telling the relay,
please connect me to zappos.com.
All right, so we'll
add some encryption.
We'll maybe do TLS on
all of these links.
So to the extent that you
can't break TLS, to the extent
you can't correlate
this to this,
then they get some privacy.
Well, that's still not
good enough, though.
Because first off, we're
assuming that this relay
is fully trusted.
I assume you know the
definition of trusted
and why it doesn't
actually mean trusted.
OK, good.
This is trusted in
the sense that it
can break the whole system,
trusted in the sense
that you can't help but trust
it, not trusted in the sense
that it's actually trustworthy.
So all right, we can
introduce multiple relays.
We can have different relays
run by different people.
We can have-- this is not
actually the topology we use.
But my blackboard
technique is terrible,
and I don't want
to redraw anything.
We can imagine tumbling
these connections
through multiple
relays, each of which
removes a single
layer of encryption.
So all this relay sees is
Alice is doing something.
All this relay sees is
someone is buying socks.
But this one just sees
The connection came
from this relay.
This one just sees Alice
is doing something,
and it forwards onto this relay.
And no single party ought
to be able to correlate
the whole thing.
Now we come to a
major design point.
Let's suppose that Eve is
watching here and here.
Nothing I've said
so far does anything
to obscure the timing and
volume of Alice's packets.
Oh sure, there'll be
some trivial noise
added from all the
computation and decryption
these things do from
network latency and so on.
But ultimately, if Alice
is sending a kilobyte in,
then the design I've
sketched out so far,
a kilobyte is coming out.
And if the socks web
page is 64k long,
and is served by this
web server at 11:26,
then Alice is going
to get something
about 64k long at
11:26 or 11:27 or so.
Now, with some
statistics, Eve can
correlate some of these
streams if we don't obscure
volume and timing information.
There are designs that do
obscure volume and timing
information.
The good ones usually
come out of [INAUDIBLE],
although there's
some work on DC-nets.
You could have something
where each of these nodes
received a large number of
requests, just [INAUDIBLE]
up all the requests
they got for an hour,
reordered them, and
transmitted them all at once.
And you could also say all
requests must be the same size.
Requests are 1k,
responses are 1 megabyte.
And with some more
work on that, we
get something that would let you
send an email that would arrive
in order of hours, or get a web
page in order of to end time,
assuming that you optimize
it to a single round trip.
These systems exist, and existed
when we started doing Tor.
They don't get a
lot of use, though.
I actually wrote
one called Mixminion
that was a successor to
the Mixmaster remailer.
I have not gotten a remailer
message in the last three
years.
Tor has billions of users.
Remailers, it's unclear
whether they've got more than
on the order of hundreds.
So you might think,
well, still though, it's
better anonymity for the
people who really need it.
Except if you've only got on
the order of hundreds of users,
then you're not
really providing them
all that much anonymity against
this kind of adversary anyway.
Because this adversary
can simply go,
OK, there's 100 people.
Well, the message I
want to investigate
was looking at a
Bulgarian website.
How many of them
speak Bulgarian?
OK, that's five.
The saying is,
anonymity loves company.
Unless you have a
large user base,
no system can actually
provide anonymity.
And that's why also in this
design, if these Alices all
belong to an
organization, they ought
to have a shared public system
rather than a private one.
If they all work for
MIT legal, and they're
investigating some
fake MIT website that's
offering fake diplomas,
then if they're just
using the MIT legal anonymizer,
then it's not really
concealing who they are.
But if you have a large
number of different parties
all using this, then it actually
can provide some privacy.
So we'll return one more time
to resisting these correlation
attacks.
But for now let's say that we're
not resisting these correlation
attacks.
And instead, we assume that
an attacker who sees both ends
wins, and we're trying to
minimize the probability
that that happens over time.
All right, so I've just
talked about message passing.
The way you would build that
with something like a mix net
is you give each of these relays
a public key-- K3, K2, K1.
And when Alice wants to
send something through here,
she would say, encrypt
with K3, socks,
and then encrypt
that with K2-- I'm
leaving off writing
information for now--
and then encrypt with K1.
But public key, as
you know, is kind
of expensive enough that you
don't want to use it for bulk
traffic.
So instead what you
do is you negotiate
a set of keys with each server.
So Alice shares a symmetric
key with this relay,
a different symmetric
and a different symmetric key
with this relay associated
in what we call a circuit, which
is a path through the network.
And after the initial public key
is set up to create those keys,
Alice can then use
symmetric crypto
to send stuff
through the network.
If you stop at that
point, then you
have onion routing as it
was designed in the 1990s
by Syverson,
Goldschlag, and Reed.
And I hope I get
the names right.
Paul Syverson is still active.
The other two are
working on other things.
Also, once you've added circuits
like that, medium term paths
through the network, you can
have an easy reply channel
where things sent
back this way get
to Alice being encrypted at
each step instead of decrypted
at each step.
And of course you need some
kind of integrity checking,
either node by
node or end to end.
Because if you don't
do integrity checking,
then-- well, let's say you're
using an XOR based stream
cypher for your encryption.
If you don't do
integrity checking,
then this node can XOR in
Alice, Alice, Alice, Alice,
Alice to the encrypted message.
And then when it's finally
decrypted over here,
because that's a
malleable crypto
scheme, if the same attacker is
controlling this node as well,
or if the attacker
is observing it here,
the attacker will see Alice,
Alice, Alice, Alice, Alice
XORed with a
reasonable plain text
and be able to use
that to identify,
ah, this is the stream
that came from Alice.
So let's do a little more
about how the protocol works.
Because it would be a shame to
have everybody read the paper
and then not talk
about the stuff
that the paper is focused on.
Again, I apologize for
my blackboard technique.
Most of the time, I'm
sitting at home on a desktop.
This is alien tech.
So here's a relay.
Here's Alice.
Here's another relay.
Here's Bob.
Now Alice wants to talk to Bob.
So first thing Alice has
to do is build a circuit
through these relays to Bob.
Let's say she's picked
these two, R1 and R2.
So Alice first makes
a TLS link to R1.
R1, let's say, already
has a TLS link to R2.
First thing Alice
does is she does
a one-way authenticated one-way
anonymous key negotiation.
The old one in
Tor is called TAP.
The new one is called NTor.
They both have proofs.
They both even have
correct proofs,
although the original proof
in the paper had a flaw in it.
But when that's done,
she sends a create cell.
And she picks a circuit ID.
Let's say she picks
3, and says, create 3.
The relay says, created.
And now R1 and Alice share a
secret key, a symmetric key,
which they're going to call S1.
And they both have this stored
as 3 with respect to this link.
Now Alice can use that key
to send messages to R1.
So she says, on 3-- that's
the circuit ID that everything
was talking about in the
paper-- send a relay extend
with some contents.
The extend cell basically
contains the first half
of the create handshake.
But this time, it's not
encrypted with R1's public key.
It's encrypted with
R2's public key.
And it also says, and
this one goes to R2.
So R1 knows to open a new
circuit to R2, and says,
create.
And it passes the initial
part of the handshake
as it came from Alice along.
And it picks its own circuit ID.
Because circuit IDs identify
the different circuits
on this TLS connection.
And Alice doesn't know
what other circuit
IDs are in use on this one.
Because this one is
private to R1 and R2.
So it might pick 95.
It actually is very
unlikely to pick that,
because they're randomly
chosen from a 4 byte space.
But I don't want to write
out any 32-bit numbers today.
And this says,
created in response.
So this one sends back an
extended encrypted with S1.
And now Alice and
relay share S2.
So now Alice can send
messages encrypted
first with S2, and then
with S1 as relay cells.
So she sends a
message like that.
R1 removes the S1 encryption
and forwards it on.
It says, OK, it came
in on circuit 3.
I know that 3 goes
to 95 on this one.
So I send it on 95.
And I say whatever I
got after decrypting.
OK, and this one says,
ah, I came on 95.
95 corresponds to
the shared key S2.
So I'll decrypt with that.
Oh, that says, open
a connection to Bob.
And relay 2 opens a
TCP connection to Bob
and tells Alice that it did
it through the same process.
And Alice says, great.
Tell Bob http 10 get/index.html,
and the world goes on.
Let's see, what did I leave out?
I'll skip that, skip
that, skip that.
So what do we actually relay?
Some designs in this area
say, well, you should
send IP packets back and forth.
This should just be a way
to transmit IP packets.
One of the problems
with that is we
want to support as many
users as possible, which
means we have to run on all
kinds of operating systems.
And operating system
TCP stacks do not
act anything like each other.
If you've ever used
Nmap, or if you've ever
used any kind of network
traffic analysis tool,
you can trivially tell
Windows TCP from FreeBSD
from Linux TCP.
And you can even tell
different versions apart.
And moreover, if you
can send raw IP packets
to a chosen host,
you can provoke
different responses
in part based
on what the host is doing.
So if you're doing
IP, you would actually
need an IP normalization
layer if IP is what
you transport back and forth.
And it seems that anything less
than a full IP stack is not
actually going to work
for IP normalization.
So you wouldn't want to do that.
Instead, what we just chose
is-- and this is largely
because this is the
easiest way-- you take
the contents of TCP streams.
So you just assume
each of these things
is reliable and in order.
You have the computer analysis
end, the program analysis
running to do all
this stuff for her,
accept TCP connections
from Alice's applications,
and then just relay
their contents
and don't do anything
trickier on the network level.
You might be able to
get better performance
by trying some other means.
And there are some
papers examining
how you would do that.
But this is the one that we
could actually implement.
Because we paid a
lot more attention
in security and
compilers classes than we
did in networking classes.
Now we have networking people.
But in 2003, 2004, we did not
have any networking experts.
TCP also seems like
the right level.
Higher level
protocols-- like in some
of the original
[INAUDIBLE] designs,
there were separate proxies
at this end for HTTP,
for FTP, and so on.
That seems to be
mostly a bad idea.
Because any
interesting protocol is
going to have end to end
encryption from Alice
all the way to Bob.
That is if we're lucky, Alice
is doing a TLS connection
over this to Bob so that TLS
properties get her integrity
and secrecy.
But if that's the case,
then any kind anonymizing
transformations you want to
apply to the encrypted data
need to happen in
the application
Alice is using before
the TLS happens entirely.
So you can't really
do that in a proxy.
And that's kind of
why we came out to,
OK, the sweet spot
is TCP contents.
Somebody asked me, OK, but
where are your security proofs?
We do have security proofs for a
lot of the cryptography that we
use, standard reductions.
For the protocol
as a whole, there
are proofs in the field about
certain aspects of onion
routing.
But the models that they
have to use in order
to prove that this
provides anonymity
make assumptions about
the universe, the network,
or the attacker's abilities
that are so weird as
to satisfy no one but certain
program committees of more
theoretical conferences.
The kind of things you can prove
is that an attacker who sees
this, who sees a number of
strings here all of equal
volume and equal timing, cannot
tell which one goes to which
Bob simply by looking
at the bytes coming out.
But that's hardly
a useful result.
Also, the kind of guarantee you
can get from anonymity systems
that we know how to
build today-- OK,
I should be careful here.
There are some where you
have very strong guarantees
that we do know how to
build that you would never
actually want to use.
Like classical
[INAUDIBLE] DC-nets,
for instance, provide
guaranteed anonymity.
Except any participant can
shut down the whole network
by not participating.
That does not scale.
But for the things
that we do want
to build these days,
for the most part,
the anonymity properties
are probabilistic rather
than categorically
guarantee-able.
So instead of asking,
does this protect
Alice, the kind of
questions you could ask
are, under this assumption
about hacker capabilities, how
much traffic can
Alice safely send
if she wants a 99% chance of not
being linked to her activities?
So will anyone actually
run these things?
That was an opening
question when we started.
We didn't know whether
the system would actually
take off or not.
So the only [INAUDIBLE]
try to see what happens.
We got a fair amount
of volunteer operators.
A fair number of non-profits
have formed whose sole purpose
is just to take donations and
use it to buy bandwidth and run
Tor nodes.
And there are also universities.
There's also private companies.
For a while, [INAUDIBLE]
was running a Tor server
out of their security
team because they
thought it was fun.
The legal issues there--
again, I'm not a lawyer.
I can't offer legal advice.
But five different people
asked about legal issues.
As far as I can tell,
in the US at least,
there's no legal impediment
to running a Tor server.
And that seems to be the case
throughout most of Europe
as far as I'm aware.
In places that generally
have less internet freedom,
it's a dicier proposition.
The issues to be
concerned about are not,
is it illegal to
run a Tor server,
but if somebody does something
illegal or undesirable
with my Tor server, will
my ISP shut me down,
and will law
enforcement believe, oh,
you're just running
a Tor server,
or will they seize the
computer to make sure?
For those, I would suggest
not running the Tor server out
of your dorm room.
Excuse me, don't run an
exit out of your dorm room,
or really out of your dorm room,
assuming the network policy
allows that.
I have no idea.
They've changed so
much since I was a kid.
Running an exit out of your dorm
room could get you in trouble.
But running a non-exit relay
that doesn't deliver traffic
to the internet is less
likely to create those issues
in particular.
But if you do it in
a nice co-lo site,
and you get your
ISP's permission,
then it's a pretty
reasonable thing to do.
Let's see, someone asked,
well, what if users
don't trust a particular node?
And this brings me
to my next topic.
So the software the clients
use, you can't tell it,
don't use this one, don't use
this one, only use this one.
But remember that anonymity
loves company principle.
If I'm only using
three nodes, and you're
using three different
nodes, and you're
using three different nodes,
our traffic will not mix at all.
To the extent that we partition
off which parts of the network
we use, we are distinguishable
from one another.
Now, if I just exclude
one or two nodes,
and you just exclude
that's not a big partitioning,
and that doesn't help
distinguish-ability that much.
But it would be good to
the extent possible to have
everyone using the same nodes.
So all right, how do
we accomplish that?
So version one, in the
first version of Tor,
we just chipped a list
of all of the nodes.
I think there were three of
them, or five, or something.
No, I think there
were about six,
of which three were all
running on the same computer
in a closet at LCS
in Tech Square.
All right, so that
wasn't a good idea.
Because nodes can
go up and down.
Nodes change.
You don't want to
have to put out
a new release of your
software every time somebody
joins to release the network.
So you could just
have every node keep
a list of all the other nodes
that are connected to it
and all advertise to each other.
And then when a client
connects, a client just
has to know one
node and then says,
hey, who's on the network?
And actually, a lot
of designs people
have built work this way.
A lot of early peer to
peer anonymity designs work
this way.
But it's a terrible idea.
Because if you go to one node
and say, who's on the network,
and you believe them, well,
if I'm that node, I can say,
yes, I'm on the network,
and my friend over here
is on the network, and my friend
over here is on the network,
and no one else
is on the network.
And I can tell you any
number of fake nodes
that are all operated by me
and capture all of your traffic
that way with what's called
a row capture attack.
OK, so maybe we just
have a single directory
operated by a trusted party.
That's not so good as a
single point of failure.
So OK, let's have
multiple trusted parties.
And clients go to these
multiple trusted parties
and get a list of all of
the nodes from all of them
and combine those lists.
Then you're
actually-- first off,
you're partitioned in that case.
If I choose these three,
and you choose those three,
and they say anything
different, then we'll
be using different
sets of nodes.
So that's still not good.
Also, there's
still a [INAUDIBLE]
where if I use the intersection
of the sets they tell me,
then any one of them can keep
me from using a node they
don't like by not listing it.
If I use the union,
anyone can flood me
by making 20,000 fake servers
that are all on the list.
I might compute the result
of some sort of vote
on them, which would
solve those two problems.
But I'd still be
partitioned from everyone
who's using different
trusted parties.
We could do a magical DHT.
Have we done
[INAUDIBLE] hash tables?
All right, we could do some
sort of magical distributed
structure run across
all of the nodes.
I say magical, because although
there are designs in this area,
and some better than
others, none of them
really seem to have a solid
security evidence for it
at this point to
the point where I
would be comfortable in saying,
yes, this is actually secure.
So the solution we
wound up with is
have multiple hardened
trusted authorities run
by trusted parties that
collect lists of nodes
that vote hourly on
which nodes are running
that can vote to exclude nodes
that seem to be misbehaving
that are all running on the
same slash 16 that are doing
strange things to
traffic, and have
them form a consensus that's
a result of their votes.
And everybody signs
the consensus.
And clients don't
use it unless it's
signed by enough authorities.
This is not the final design.
But it's the best we've
managed to come up with so far.
And this way, all you
need to distribute
with clients is a list of all
of the authorities' public keys
and some places to
get the directories.
You want to have all the nodes
cache these directory things.
Because if you don't, the
bandwidth load on authorities
is catastrophic.
So I'm going to skip over that.
Because I would love
to talk about how
clients should
choose which paths
to build through the network.
I would love to talk
about issues applications
and making applications
not deanonymize themselves.
I'd love to talk about abuse.
I'd love to talk about hidden
services and how they work.
I'd love to talk about
censorship resistance.
And I'd like to talk about
attacks and defenses.
But I've only got 35 minutes.
And I can't possibly
cover all of these.
So show of hands
for how many people
think the most important--
think about what you think
are the two most important
topics on this list.
If one of your two
most important topics
is path selection and
how you choose nodes,
please raise your hand.
If one of your two
most important topics
is application issues and
how to make applications not
bust your anonymity,
please raise your hand.
If one of your most
important issues
is abuse and what kind of abuse
we see, how you can prevent it,
and how that works out,
please raise your hand.
OK, that one's popular.
If one of your most
important topics
is how these
services work and how
they can be made to work
better, please raise your hand.
Wow, that's much more popular
on this side of the room
than that side of the room.
What's going on?
You guys in a club?
Are you up to something?
Censorship, who's
interested in censorship?
OK, that's fairly popular.
Attacks and defenses?
OK, so we're not doing paths
and we're not doing apps.
So apps-- guard nodes, guard
nodes, C guard node designs,
select by bandwidth.
You need to actually
weight by bandwidth,
but you also need a trusted
way to measure bandwidth.
And that's the too long,
didn't lecture of what
would be on path selection.
For application issues,
almost no protocol
is actually designed
to provide anonymity.
Because almost every
protocol that's widely used
has the assumption
in it, well, you
know, anyone who
wants to can just
see the IPs on this traffic.
So there's no point in
trying to conceal identity.
So in a particularly
complex protocol,
like the whole stack of
protocols a web browser uses,
there's no real way
to anonymize that
just by anonymizing the traffic
with something like Tor.
You need to hack the
web browser pretty hard
to make it stop doing things
like leaking the list of fonts
that are identified
on your system,
leaking your exact
window size, allowing
all kinds of permanent
cookie-like structures,
leaking what's in the cache
and what's not in the cache,
and so on.
So your choices
there are basically
isolate everything and restart
from a fresh VM all the time,
or reroute the browser, or both.
Other things are a lot
easier than web browsers,
but still problematic.
That's all I'm going to
say about app issues.
Let's see, I think
I got the most
hands-- did you see what
I got the most hands for,
any opinions?
STUDENT: Abuse and
hidden services?
NICK MATHEWSON: Abuse
and hidden services.
All right, I'll talk about
abuse and hidden services.
And if I've still got time,
I'll do censorship and attacks.
So let's go to abuse--
abuse, abuse, abuse.
So one problem that
we've fortunately not
had all that much of-- so when
we were working on this stuff,
the problem that
everybody was afraid of
was this horrible stuff that
would get you kicked off
of any ISP, and it would
create tremendous legal issues
and ruin your lives.
I speak of course
of file sharing.
We were terrified
that people would
try to BitTorrent or Gnutella
or whatever over this thing.
Yes, it was a long time ago.
And we thought about
how we'd do that.
Well, you'll see in the paper
that we talk a lot about exit
policies, about
letting exit nodes say,
I only allow connections
to port 80 and port 443.
This doesn't actually
help with abuse at all.
Because you can try to
spread worms over port 80.
You can post abusive stuff
to IRC channels over web
to IRC interfaces.
Everything's got a web
interface these days.
So you can't really
say, it's only web.
It's safe.
If it's useful,
it can be abused.
That said, there
are people who are
willing to run exits
that deliver 80 and 443
who would not be willing to
run exits delivering all ports.
So it did turn out to be useful.
It just didn't turn
out to be a solution.
Another thing that creates
problems is criminal activity
generally doesn't create
problems for the network
operators so much.
From time to time, somebody's
server gets seized and returned
six months later, and they
have to wipe the thing.
That's still an infrequent
enough occurrence
that it's somewhat
surprising when it happens.
And so yeah, don't run
an exit node on a server
that you need to graduate.
What else?
The biggest problem that
we have for abuse of stuff
is that many websites
around the world,
and many IRC
services and so one,
use IP-based blocking in
order to deter and mitigate
abusive behavior-- people
posting road kill pictures
on My Little Pony sites,
people flaming everybody
on IRC channels,
people making love,
leave, join requests, people
replacing entire Wikipedia
pages with racial slurs.
This stuff it's real.
It's problematic.
It's unacceptable to the
websites and services
that use IP-based blocking.
They need a way to keep
this from happening.
And IP-based blocking is a
cheap way for them to do that.
So it's pretty frequent that
Tor users get banned completely
from some sites.
There's some work on trying to
say, well, why does IP-based
blocking really work?
Is it because IPs are people?
No.
Everybody in this room knows
how to get a different IP
if they need one.
Everybody in this room knows how
to get like tens of thousands
of different IPs
if they need one,
if they need tens of thousands.
But for most people,
getting more IPs
is at least a little time
consuming and at least
a little challenging to the
extent that it imposes a rate
limit and a resource
cost on abuse
if you don't want a bot net
and if they've already blocked
Tor and all the
other proxy services.
So for that, you need to
look at different ways
to provide other resource costs.
You can either say, well--
have you done blind signatures?
Oh, you can construct
things so that you
need an IP to make an account.
But what account
you make with an IP
is not linkable to your IP.
And then later on if
the account gets banned,
you need to create a new
account from a different IP.
That's something you can build,
and we're working with people
to work on it, although it needs
more hacking on the integration
side.
Something else that needs more
hacking on the integration side
is anonymous black
listable credentials.
They're a little esoteric.
But the idea is that
you get something
that allows you to participate
on an IRC server, for example.
You can use this as
many times as you want.
Your using it is not linkable
until you are banned.
Once you are banned,
future attempts
from the same person with the
same credential don't work.
But past activities do not
become linkable to one another.
These can be built
pretty easily.
The problem is convincing people
who are more or less satisfied
with IP blocking to
actually use them
and actually integrating
them with services.
Someone inevitably asks
me-- it's kind of neat.
So I started these lecture notes
based on my lecture from 2013.
And there was something
about the inevitable question
about Silk Road
1 getting busted.
There's the inevitable
question about Silk Road 2
getting busted.
Silk Road 2 was a hidden service
operating on the Tor network
where people would get
together to buy and sell
illegal things,
mostly illegal drugs.
So as far as we know, as
far as we can find out,
the guy got busted
through bad OPSEC.
Like he made a public
posting with his actual name,
and then went and deleted it
and put his pseudonym on it.
Tor can't help people
against that kind of stuff.
On the other hand, if you've
been looking at the NSA leaks,
you know that law enforcement
has been getting information
from intelligence and
then sanitizing it
through a process called
dual construction where
the intelligence agency will say
to the law enforcement agency,
OK, look, it's Fred over there.
He did it.
But that's not
admissible in a court,
and you can never
admit that we told you.
Just find some other way to
find out that Fred did it,
but Fred did it.
According to some
of the Snowden leaks
and some of the leaks
from the other guy, who
has still not been caught,
that's done sometimes.
So OK, at this point, you use
your basic Bayesian reasoning
skills, and you say,
well OK, would I
see this evidence
if the guy actually
got caught by because of OPSEC?
Yes, I would.
I would see bad OPSEC.
I would see reports that he got
caught because of bad OPSEC.
But what would I see if it
were a dual construction case?
I would also see
reports that the guy
got caught by bad OPSEC.
Because the evidence that
would be available to
us is the same in either case.
We can't really conclude
much from any public reports
of that.
That said, it does look like
the guy got busted by bad OPSEC.
It does look like
the kind of bad OPSEC
that you would be
looking for if you
were trying to catch somebody
running something like this.
Nevertheless, earlier I
suggested that please do not
use myself to break any laws.
Also if you're life or
freedom is at stake from using
Tor or any security
product, do not
use that product in isolation.
Think of ways to
use it to construct
a series of redundant
defenses for yourself
if your life or
freedom at stake,
or if having the
system broken is
completely unacceptable to you.
And I'll say that about Tor.
And I'll say that about TLS.
And I'll say that about PGP.
Software is a work in progress.
So that's the abuse section.
I've got 25 minutes--
hidden services.
Where's hidden services?
So responder anonymity
is a much harder problem
than initiator anonymity.
Initiator anonymity
is what you get
when Alice wants to
buy socks, and Alice
wants to stay anonymous
from the sock vendor.
Responder anonymity
is when Alice
wants to publish her
poetry online and run a web
server that has
her poetry on it,
but not let anyone know
where that web server is
because the poetry
is so embarrassing.
And yes there actually
is a hidden service
out there of mine
with bad poetry on it.
No, I don't think anybody's
actually published it yet.
No, I'm not going to
tell anybody where it is.
I'm waiting for it to go public.
So all right, one thing
you could do is-- let's
see, how much time?
OK, I can do this.
So now Alice wants to
publish her poetry.
So I'm going to put
Alice on this end,
because she's the responder.
Alice could build a path-- this
represents a lot of relays--
through the Tor network, and
then just say to this relay,
please accept connections.
So now anyone who goes
to this relay could say,
hey, I want to talk to Alice.
And there have been
designs that work this way.
It has some challenges, though.
One challenge is this relay
could man in the middle
all the traffic unless there
is a well known TLS key.
Another thing is
maybe this relay
is also embarrassed
by the poetry
and doesn't want to
be a public contact
point for poetry so terrible.
So this relay could also be
pressured by other people who
hate the poetry to censor it.
This relay could also make
itself an attack target.
So you want some way where Alice
can go to different relays over
time and no single relay is
touching unencrypted traffic
of Alice's.
All right, that's doable.
But once you have a lot
of different relays,
what does Alice
actually tell people?
It's kind of got
to be a public key.
Because if she just says, relay
x, relay y, relay z, but x, y,
and z are changing
every five minutes,
that's kind of challenging
to know you actually
got the right relay.
So let's say she tells
everybody a public key,
and once she gets over here,
she says, hey, this is Alice.
I'll prove it with
my public key.
So this relay knows
that public key z is
running a hidden service here.
And so if anyone else says,
hey, connect me to public key z,
they can do a
handshake and wind up
with a shared key with Alice.
And it's the same handshake as
the Tor circuit extension uses.
And now Bob can
read Alice's poetry
by going another path through
the Tor network over here.
Bob has to know PKz, and Bob can
say, hey, connect me with PKz.
Send this thing that's sort
of like a create cell--
really it's an introduce
cell, but let's
forget that-- over the Alice.
They do the same
handshake that relays do.
And now they have a
shared key that they can
use for end to end encryption.
Well, there's something
I left out, though,
which is, how does Bob
know how to go here?
And can we do anything
about the fact
that this relay has to
learn to this public key?
Well, we can.
We can add some [INAUDIBLE]
directory system
where Alice uploads a signed
statement anonymously over Tor
saying PKz is at a relay x.
And then Bob says, hey,
give me a signed statement
to ask the directory
system, hey, give me
a signed statement about PKz.
And Bob finds out where to go.
And we could even do one
better and have Alice give
a different public key here.
So this could be PKw.
And the statement she uploads
to the directory can say,
if you want to talk to the
service with public key z,
then go to relay x
and use public key w.
And now public key z
isn't published here.
You could even go one
farther and encrypt this
with some shared secret
known to Alice and Bob.
And if you do that, then
the directory service
and people who can contact
can't learn how to connect
to Alice with that.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Just a
quick question there.
If that's not encrypted,
then Rx can still
find out that it's running
a service for Alice, right?
NICK MATHEWSON: Yep.
Well, not for Alice.
It can find out that
it's running PKz
if this is not encrypted.
We have a design for that
that I'm actually going
to get to at the end of this.
But it's not built yet.
But it's pretty cool.
So OK, and you don't want to
use a centralized directory
for this.
So we actually do use a DHT,
which is, again, not perfect,
and has some censorship
opportunities.
But we are trying to
make those less and less.
And I might cover more stuff,
so I can't do the whole details.
So one of the
problems there though
is if you are running one
of these directory services,
you've got a complete list of
these keys pretty-- over time,
you run a directory
service [INAUDIBLE].
You get a complete
list of all these keys,
and you can try
connecting to all the ones
that don't have encrypted
stuff to find out what's there.
That's called an
enumeration attack.
And we didn't list
that in our paper,
because we weren't
thinking of that.
We didn't.
But it is something
we'd like to resist.
So in the design I hope
to be hacking together
sometime in 2014, we're going
to move towards a key blinding
approach where Alice
and Bob share PKz,
but this statement is
not signed with PKz.
This statement is
signed with PKz prime
where PKz prime is
derived from PKz
and, say, the date such that
if you know PKz and the date,
you can derive PKz prime.
If like Alice you
know secret Kz,
you can generate messages
that are signed by PKz prime.
But if you only see PKz
prime, even knowing the date,
you cannot re-derive PKz.
We've got a proof.
And if you'd like to find out
how this works, then ping me
and I'll send you the paper.
It's a cool trick.
We weren't the first
ones to invent this idea.
But that is how we're going
to solve enumeration attacks
sometime this coming year
assuming that I can actually
get the time to build it.
So that's hidden services.
Attacks and
defenses-- so so far,
the biggest category
of attacks we've seen
is attacks at the
application level.
So if you're running an
application over Tor,
and it's sending unencrypted
traffic, like regular HTTP,
then a hostile exit
node, just like anyone
else who touches HTTP traffic,
can observe and modify
the traffic.
This is the number one
attack on the whole system.
The solution is
encrypted traffic.
Fortunately, we're kind of
in an encryption renaissance
over the last few years.
And more and more
traffic is getting
encrypted with the nifty
free certificate authority
that EFF and Mozilla and Cisco
and I forget who else announced
a day or two ago.
There will be even less excuse
for unencrypted traffic in 2015
than there was this year.
So that solves that.
More interesting attacks include
things like traffic tagging.
So we made a mistake in our
early integrity checking
implementation.
Our early integrity
checking implementation
did end to end checking between
Alice's program and the exit
node.
But it turns out that
that's not enough.
Because if the
first relay messes
with the traffic in a way that
creates a pattern that the exit
node can detect, then
that's an easy way
for the first relay
and the last relay
to learn that they are on the
same path and identify Alice.
Of course, if the first
relay and the last relay
happen to be on the
same path, happen
to be collaborating anyway,
then they can already
identify Alice through traffic
correlation, we believe.
But perhaps it should not
be so easy for them as that.
Perhaps traffic
correlation will someday
be harder than we think.
It would be good to actually
solve that attack for real.
We've got two
solutions for that.
One is the expected
result of this attack
is that periodically
circuits will fail.
Because the attacker
on the first hop
guessed wrong about
controlling the last hop.
So every Tor client checks
for weird failure rates.
The real long-term
fix is to make it
so that messing with the
pattern on the first hop
doesn't create more than 1 bit
of information on the last hop.
You can't avoid sending
1 bit of information,
because the first hop can always
just shut down the connection.
But you can limit it
to 1 bit-- OK, 2 bits.
Because then they'll have the
choice to corrupt the data
or shut down the connection.
Oh, I had an idea of
how to make that better.
I'll have to think about that.
Let's see, DOS is
actually pretty important.
There was a paper the
other year about something
that the authors called
the sniper attack
where you see traffic
coming from a Tor node
that you don't control.
You want to kick everybody
off that Tor node.
So you connect to it.
You fill up all its memory
buffers, and it crashes.
Then you see whether
the traffic in question
gets rerouted to a node
you control or not,
and you repeat as necessary.
For that, our best
options are first off,
no longer have memory DOSes.
I think we have all of the
good memory DOSes fixed now.
There are some bad ones that
still needed to get addressed.
But they're screamingly
inefficient.
The other option for
resolving this kind of thing
is make sure relays
are high capacity.
Don't accept low capacity
relays on the network.
We do that, too.
If you're trying to run
a relay on your phone,
the authorities won't list it.
And another thing is to try
to pick our circuit scheduling
algorithms so that it's
hard to starve out circuits
that you don't control.
That's very hard,
though, and it's as yet
an unsolved problem.
Let's see, should I do
an interesting attack
or an important attack?
STUDENT: Interesting.
NICK MATHEWSON: Interesting, OK.
So show of hands,
how many people
might like to write
a program that
uses cryptography some day?
Cool, here's what
you must learn.
Never trust your
cryptography implementation.
So even when it's
correct, it's wrong.
So long ago-- I think this may
be one of the worse security
bugs that we've had.
Any relay could
man in the middle
any circuit because we assumed
that a correct Diffie-Hellman
implementation would verify
that it was not being passed 0
as one of the inputs.
The authors of our
Diffie-Hellman implementation
assumed the proper
application would never
pass zero to a Diffie-Hellman
implementation.
So Diffie-Hellman, when I say
g to the x, you say g to the y.
I know x.
You know y.
And we can both compute
g to the xy now.
You tend to feel me?
Good.
Well, if instead the
man in the middle
replaces my g to the x with
0 and your g to the x with 0,
and then I happily
compute 0 to the x,
and you compute 0 to the y,
we will have the same key.
We will happily
talk to each other.
But this will be a key that the
attacker knows, because it's 0.
1 also works.
p also works.
p plus 1 also works.
So you basically just need to
make sure that your values here
are within range 2 and p minus
1 if you're doing Diffie-Hellman
in z sub p.
OK, let's see, I would love
to talk more about censorship.
Because actually,
it's one of the areas
where we can do the most good.
Generally, the summarized
version of that
was, in the earliest
paper you read,
and in some of the updates,
we were still on the idea
that we would try to
make Tor look just
like a web client talking
to a web server over HTTPS
and make that hard to block.
It turns out that's
fantastically difficult
and probably not worth doing.
Instead, the
approach we take now
is using different
plug-in programs
that a non-listed relay
called a bridge can use,
and a client can use
to do different traffic
transformations.
And we manage to keep
adding new ones of those
faster than the censors
have been able to implement
blocking for them.
And that's actually a case
where none of the solutions
are categorically workable.
That's not a
well-formed sentence.
None of these plug-ins
are inherently
unblockable by any
imaginable technique so far.
But they're good enough to keep
traffic unblocked for a year
or two in most places,
and six or seven
months at a time in China.
China currently has the most
competent censors in the world,
largely because China
doesn't outsource.
Most other censoring countries
outsource their censorship
to dishonest European, American,
and Asian companies whose
incentives are not actually
to sell them good censorship,
but to keep them on
an upgrade treadmill.
So if you were buying
your censorship software
from the United States--
which technically speaking
US companies aren't allowed
to make censorship software
for nations.
But they just make
corporate firewall software
that happens to scale
to 10 million people.
Yeah, I think that's unethical.
But again, I'm not the political
scientist of the organization,
or the philosopher.
Paul Syverson, one of the
original [INAUDIBLE] authors,
does have a degree
in philosophy,
for what that's worth,
which means that he can't
answer these questions either.
But he takes a lot longer
not to answer them.
Right, where was I?
90 minutes is a long time.
Censorship-- right, so what
the censorware providers
do is once Tor gets
around their censorship,
they will block the most
recent version of Tor.
But they do it in a way that
is the weakest possible block.
So if we change 1 bit in
one identifier somewhere,
we get around it.
We can't prove that they're
doing this on purpose
to ensure that Tor will evade
their version so that they can
sell Tor blocking and then have
it not work so they can sell
the upgrade, and then
sell the next upgrade,
and sell the next upgrade.
But it sure does seem that way.
So that's another reason not to
work for censorship providers.
They're tremendously
unethical, and they don't
provide very good software.
If you're interested
in writing any
of these plug-able
transport things,
that is an excellent
kind of thing
to do as a student
project-- loads of fun,
learn a little bit
about crypto, learn
a little bit about networking.
And so long as you do it
in a memory-safe language,
you can't screw
it up that badly.
The worst thing
that happens is it
gets censored after a month
instead of after a year.
And that's what I want to-- oh,
the addenda related to work.
Tor is the most popular
system of its kind,
but it's not the only one.
Lots of others have
really good ideas,
and you should
check them out too
if you're interested
in learning all
of the stuff I'm
not thinking about
and all the reasons I'm wrong.
freehaven.net/anonbib/
lists the academic research
and publications in this area.
But not all the research
in this area is academic.
You should also
look at I2P; Gnunet;
Freedom, which is
currently defunct,
no pun intended; Mixmaster;
Mixminion; Sphynx with a Y,
Sphinx with an I is
something different; DC-nets,
particularly the work of Brian
Ford, and also of the team
at Technical University
Dresden, in trying
to make DC-nets practical.
They're very strong [INAUDIBLE],
not actually deployable
yet-- and many others.
Why these get less use
or attention than Tor
is an open topic
of some interest
that I don't have
a solid answer for.
Future work-- so
one of the reasons
I do these is not just
because I would like everybody
to know about the cool
software I work on.
But also because I
know students have
lots and lots of free time.
And I'm kind of
looking to recruit.
OK, you may think I'm joking.
But when I was just getting
started in this field,
I was complaining about how I
was so busy reviewing papers
for one conference, writing
software, fixing a bug,
answering email.
I was complaining to some
senior faculty member.
And he told me, you will
never have so much free time
as you do today.
You actually have
a lot more free
time now than you
will in 10 years.
So this is a great time to work
on crazy software projects.
So let me tell you about
future work in Tor.
There's this key blinding
thing and a complete revamp
of our hidden
services system, which
was the best we could design
when we came up with it.
But there's been a lot
of research since then.
Maybe some of it will turn
out to be a good idea.
We're also revamping
most of our crypto.
We chose schemes that
seemed like a good security
performance trade-off
in 2003, like RSA-1024.
We've replaced the
really important uses
of RSA-1024 with stronger stuff,
currently [INAUDIBLE] 25519.
But there's still
some cases that we
want to replace in the protocol
that we need some work on.
I didn't talk too much
about path selection,
so I can't talk too much about
improvements in that selection.
But our path selection
algorithms were [INAUDIBLE].
And there's been
some awesome research
in the past five or six years on
that that we need to integrate.
There's a little
work that's been
done on mixing high latency
and low latency traffic so
that the low latency
traffic can provide cover
for the high latency traffic
in terms of providing lots
of users while the high latency
traffic is still very well
anonymized.
It's not clear whether
this would work or not.
anyone would use this or not.
And it is clear that
unless something changes,
or unless some major funding
for that particularly shows up,
I'm not going to have time
to work on it in 2015.
But if somebody else wants
to hack on that, my god,
that would be fun.
Our congestion
control algorithms
were chosen questionably based
on what we could hack together
in a week.
We've improved them, but they
could use a bigger revamp.
There's some research on
scaling to hundreds of thousands
of nodes.
So in the current
design, we can probably
get up to 10,000 or
20,000 with no problem.
But because we assume that every
client knows about every node,
and every node may be
connected to every other node,
that's going to stop
scaling before 100,000.
And we need to do
something about that.
That opens up some
classes of attacks
based on attackers learning
which clients know which nodes
and using that to
distinguish clients.
So most of the naive
approaches are a bad idea here.
But it may be that less naive
approaches might work out.
Another thing you might want to
do if you're increasing 100,000
nodes is get rid of those
centralized directory
authorities and go to some
kind of peer to peer design.
I don't have extremely
high confidence
in the peer to peer
designs I know of so far.
But it could be that
somebody's about to advance
the next good one.
Let's see, I don't
know what that means.
Oh, somebody asked a
question about adding
padding traffic or fake
traffic to try to deceive end
to end traffic correlation.
This is an exciting
research field
that needs someone smarter
to work on it or someone
with a more practical attitude
to work on it than has
previously worked on it.
Too many of the results
in the research literature
there are only about
distinguishing the traffic
of two users on a number
containing one relay,
because that's how the
math was easy to do.
So because of this
kind of stuff,
all of the traffic
analysis defenses
that we know of in this
area that are still
compatible with broad
browsing, they sound good
if you read the abstract.
You'll say, hooray, this
one forces the attacker
to gather three times as
much traffic before they
can correlate users.
Except when you
actually read the paper,
previously the attacker needed
two seconds worth of traffic,
and then they won.
Now they need six seconds.
That's not really a
defence in this model,
although perhaps
against a real network,
the numbers would be
different and it might work.
So we would actually like
to see some stuff done
with padding and fake traffic.
But we don't like to
add voodoo defenses
that we conjecture to
maybe do some good,
although we can't do that.
We actually like
to have evidence
that any changes
we're going to make
are going to help something.
I think I'm out of time.
And there may be a
class in here after us?
There is not?
All right, so I'm going to
hang around for a while.
And thanks for coming to listen.
I would take questions now.
But it's 12:25, and folks
may have another class.
But I'll be around [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you very much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]